welcome my name is Rob Sanders I'm a
course instructor at simply learned
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using SEO and SEO is
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as hear us
say organic listings we're going to talk
a little bit about why you would want to
rank your website in organic search okay
what is search engine optimization then
we're going to follow that up with how
does Google rank websites so why does it
rank one website over another and how do
we get our website to rank number one
then we're going to talk about the
different types of SEO or search engine
optimization techniques so you can get
your website ranked number one and then
we're gonna finish that off with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so let's get
right to it and talk about why SEO so
we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am I not
ranking for my blog why when people type
in ice cream recipes and say Google my
blog post don't appear at the top of
organic rankings and there's a number of
reasons why you wouldn't be ranked for
your blog post or your ice cream recipes
and the main reason would be your
competitors so there could be somebody
else out there who is also passionate
about ice cream and has been blogging
along a longer than you and they have
more content and more blog post and more
pages for Google to rank so that's
usually the number one reason the other
reason is improper usage of keywords and
we're going to talk a little bit tor
it's actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in your content so what
kind of keywords do you want to rank for
that's really what we're talking about
when we talk about usage of keywords
what keywords do you want to rank for
and how do we work those keywords into
the content another reason is poor link
building practices
and really that means our other blog
post or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking or other web sites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say WordPress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if your
Google would you really want to rank a
website or blog post in this example
number one on Google rankings if that
particular page loaded very slow no you
wouldn't because when somebody clicked
on that link in organic search and went
to your website they're gonna have a bad
experience because the page is going to
load slow so Google doesn't want their
users to have a bad experience you don't
want your users to have a bad experience
and so that's why web page load time is
a critical factor for ranking so we need
to make sure that our web pages load
fast and then your user experience is
not good enough so Google again based on
my example about the web page load time
Google wants people to have a good
experience when they go from their
search engine to your website and
there's a lot at play there specifically
web page load time but also you know
Google doesn't want any spam content
Google doesn't want any pop-ups or
overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to or searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end-user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
as Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a blog with 100
suppose you want Google to have access
to all 100 recipes so we're going to
talk a little bit later about how to get
your pages ranked or indexed on Google
organic search so let's move on to what
is SEO so sticking with our icecream
blog theme really SEO search engine
optimization really is the practice of
increasing your pages that Google has
indexed up the rankings so the end
result is we want all our pages to be
ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay are talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable
these seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just mention about structure
logic readability organization title all
those things are what's important in SEO
and so we need relevant content we need
titles for our pages Google needs to be
able to see structure we need to have
synopsis of what the page is about and
that's called a meta description and
then again that the content needs to be
readable and that's important and so in
order to be readable again we're going
to talk more about site speed because
site speed is important ok man when we
talk about responsive design
when I say responsive design that means
your site your page needs a load both on
desktop and also on mobile and so all
these things are important just like an
essay competition Google is the judge
and they need to be able to determine
what page is bad
to rank number one number two number
three etc on Google search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about an off page SEO
I'm it's Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they crawl back to their servers
and when they take it back to their
servers your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into Google com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's when indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank though those pages that they've
indexed from number 1 to infinity
depending on how many pages are relevant
to that search query so really it's
about crawling indexing and ranking so
prowling is simply a process done by
which Google has BOTS and what these
bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how did they find
these pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spider but that's what they call search
engine spider in so basically what
Google is doing is they're building a
web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index so based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then they're not gonna show up for
relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available but we crawl
then we'll talk about that a little bit
later ok but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn ok I
could see I have 1 million 10,000
results
okay and that's how many results are
showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learn pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10,000 pages related to
the keywords simply learned now when you
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're gonna
see something that says add next to it
okay so we can see that there are paid
ads here but when it comes to organic
search those are generally below paid
ads and so that's where Google counts
the 1 million 10,000 results and so
that's the whole idea behind crawling
and indexing Google is able to crawl
simply learns website and based on all
the pages that they gather they're gonna
make those pages available in organic
search so if you type in a keyword and
your web page is not available for
indexing then you're never going to show
up for that keyword so that's why it's
important to make sure your website is
available for crawling and indexing and
so when a user types a query on search
Google search the most relevant websites
that are in Google's index are going up
here in the search results so in the
example I gave we simply learn well
simply learn is the brand name of the
company simply learned so there's a lot
of relevancy there so that's why you see
simply learn show up here organically
number one like we mentioned about what
is SEO and why SEO we talked about that
user experience so there's a lot of
factors that go into ranking relevancy
being one of them
so in the simply learn example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learn pages because that's who they are
simply learn however simply learn also
needs to make sure that you know for
their pages the page load time is fast
meaning these pages load very fast for
the end-user and Google also takes into
account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website ok and so the user
experiences
very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in India the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the United States why
because Google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in India their results
may be a little bit different than the
results show up in the US because Google
has different BOTS and these bots are
crawling different pages at different
times and so Google's index is updating
continuously but it's not real-time
syncing so if you do a search in India
you may not see exactly the same thing
because both search engines the Google
and India and the Google in the US or
may not be exactly synched up so an
example would be you know if you're
looking for cafe so if you search a cafe
and say San Francisco you're gonna see
different results now if you do a search
for cafes at Mumbai you're gonna see
different results there's gonna be local
search here at the top there may be some
paid search but again you may see
different results because one location
but to Google search engines in India
and United States google.com aren't
exactly synched up exactly at the same
exact time you do that search so
location is important language is
important and relevancy is important
along with user experience so all those
are important factors in how Google
ranks websites okay so we're going to
talk about the types of SEO now so if we
want to rank for a particular keyword on
Google we're going to have to apply
search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are
headers meta descriptions title tags
linking so all of those elements are
something we can control
as an end user who wants to rank our
webpage and our website on Google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're gonna get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and the number two we need
to understand what the competition is
for that keyword that you want to rank
for
so if you choose a keyword and there's
not much competition for it then chances
are you can rank for that keyword for a
webpage on your website
quicker then say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on-page SEO you can
change the title tag the meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the webpage you're trying to
rank for and so let me show you example
of how to go through this so the first
thing we want to do is we want to use a
tool and the tool I would recommend is
Google Keyword planner then why do I
choose Google Keyword planner
and for trying to rank on google.com or
Google search engine we want to be able
to get the data right from the source so
Google's going to be able to give us
information about how much volume a
keyword has and how much competition it
has so let me show you an example so if
I want to use Google's keyword planner
and I want to rank for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
then I'm gonna type that keyword into
Google's keyword planner and what Google
is gonna do is they're gonna give me
some trends about how much volume this
particular keyword gets over the course
of a year and so for that particular
keyword I can see that there are trends
that appear for both desktop and mobile
so Mobile is important because people
start their search process a lot of
times on their mobile device so we want
to be able to get data from mobile as
well as desktop and so we can see a
trend here that for each particular
month over the last 12 months we can see
how much volume this particular keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist gets per month and so on
average on average over the past twelve
months I can see how to become a digital
marketing specialist is averages 30
searches a month and this is on
google.com and so Google gives us the
volume but they also give us as the
competition and so here I can see Google
says for that particular keyword the
competition is medium and so in the
Google's keyword planner what they also
do is give me other relevant keywords
that I might think about optimizing for
because you don't want to optimize for
just one keyword so how to become a
digital marketing specialist they're
gonna also offer up other types of
keywords that are relevant so just
digital marketing specialist social
media marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is 1000 per
month on average of the last 12 months I
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords I can see
the search volume being high
like digital marketing course at 2900
per month but also the competition is
high button so what I would recommend is
a best practice is to collect all your
relevant keywords okay and put all your
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet and
when you put all these relevant keywords
in a spreadsheet you want to get the
data on those keywords and the data I'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from Google planner Google's
keyword planner and I have competition
from Google's keyword planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm gonna be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
keyword planner if we go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 million results so I can see 76
million results 76 point one actually
and for the keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist now that's
a whole lot of results for this
particular keyword especially when the
volume is only thirty per month on
average and so what I want to do is get
a more clear picture of the competition
and so what you can actually do is type
in the syntax all in title and then
colon and then your keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and when I do that I get a different
result here I can see only 136 listings
for how to become a digital marketing
specialist but that's not just 136
that's 136 with that particular keyword
that we want to rank for in the title
tag okay so the title tag is what you
see when you type in a keyword or search
query in Google search and the title tag
is what you see at the top of every
search result and so now I can see I
typed in how to become a digital
marketing
specialists with the all in title syntax
and now I can see every listing every
one of these a hundred and thirty six
results have that particular keyword in
it so I can see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
one hundred and thirty six listings to
rank for that keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist and so the
idea here is you want to get your volume
from Google's keyword planner but you
want to get your competition from Google
search and again that's simply typing in
the syntax all in title and then your
keyword in this example how to become a
digital marketing specialist once you
get those two numbers you're gonna plug
them in to your spreadsheet and then
once you do that for a number of
different keyword queries and these
keyword queries again have to be
relevant once you do that then you can
go in and pick the keywords you want to
optimize for and that's important
because again if you're not sure about a
keyword then you want to do the keyword
research so you can be sure of how much
traffic you can get and how much
competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
CEM you want to create content for say a
keyword like digital marketing but
digital marketing may seem a little bit
broad so you want to probably stay away
from broader keywords because broader
keywords tend to have a lot of volume
which is great but they may also tend to
have a lot of competition but that's the
whole point of doing the keyword
research maybe it doesn't maybe there's
more volume than competition that's what
you need to find out when you do the
keyword research you need to find those
keywords that are relevant to your
content that have a lot of volume in the
competition and then once we identify
those keywords then we are free to go in
and start optimizing our webpages for
those keywords and the first place we
want to start is the title tag so if you
remember my example going
care to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're gonna see the title
tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor is that's what
people see and so ideally when we choose
our keyword we want to make sure that
keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
truncated it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're gonna see it and they're going
to click through to your website and
that's the whole idea behind ranking we
want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
bolder than anything else
Google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the meta description
and the meta description is simply just
a brief description up to a hundred and
fifty five I would say about a hundred
and fifty five to sixty hundred and
sixty characters but probably no more
than that and so the meta description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if I go back to my Google
search results I see my title tag and I
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
Meta Description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the Meta
Description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written Meta Description within a
hundred and fifty-five characters and it
includes the keyword digital marketing
specialist so we're trying to rank for
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and here you can see become a
digital marketing specialist so there's
a lot of relevancy between not only the
title tag in the keyword but the meta
description in the key word so when
you're optimizing a keyword and you want
to start with the title tag but you also
want to update the meta description
because if you don't update the meta
description and you leave the meta
description blank then you're leaving it
to Google to add in copy that they deem
relevant and so for on-page SEO we want
to take control of the copy and we want
to optimize it for the keywords we want
to be found for so the Meta Description
is a powerful tool at our disposal it
gives us more characters to work with it
gives us more to talk about so for that
particular page and so if the title tag
is only 60 characters maximum it's not a
lot of information to try and get
somebody to click so the meta
description helps us and identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the to working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL in URL stands for Uniform
Resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
you notice that the URL also includes
how to become a digital marketing
specialist article okay so it's very
relevant the URL is very relevant one we
can see it in the search results but to
you it's relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end-user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
users query and if it is
is then this user is likely gonna have a
good excuse er experience after they
click on the listing so the URL is an
element that helps not only with the
click-through rate but with ranking and
having a poor URL structure doesn't help
at all because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor your rough structure so the rule of
thumb is this if you don't understand
what the URL is then Google is likely
not going to understand what the URL is
and so we want to try and keep our URL
structures clean and when I say clean
ideally you want to make sure that
whatever keywords you're trying to
optimize that's the keyword that's
included in the URL nothing included
that is not understandable so again
going back to our example how to become
a digital marketing specialist it's very
clean the title tag is the keyword the
Meta Description is cleanly written has
the keyword and then the URL is the
other element that the end-user can see
and that URL includes
the keyword in it so after we've done
those three elements the title tag the
meta description and the URL then we
want to start optimizing the page itself
so ideally when we say optimize the page
itself the page remember needs to be
structured and when we say structure to
need to be structured in terms of you
know headers and sub headers and
organized in a manner in which the
end-user can read the article read the
content clearly and concisely without
being confused and so that's the job of
headers they add they add basically an
organizational structure to the content
and with headers there's a hierarchy so
you have anywhere from h1 which is the
top of the hierarchy to an h6 and so
you're free to use any one of those
headers when building on a page in order
to organize the content but ideally you
probably want to stick with an h1 or an
h2 because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey
this header with this particular keyword
in it is important so if you use an h6
with the keyword in it it's telling
Google hey this is an h6 but it's not as
important so an h1 and an h2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an h1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and bolder then you have an
h2 which is going to be bigger and
bolder than an h3 but not as big and
bold as an h2 so with headers not only
you organizing the content accordingly
but you're also signaling to Google how
important that particular header is and
of course the header needs to include
the keyword we're trying to rank for so
let's take a look again at that example
so if we go to how to become a digital
marketing specialist if I click on that
page I can look at the content and I can
see that there are headers in here so
the headers are there to organize the
content and that's what we want we want
to be able to organize the content and
if you look at the other example I'm
showing here how to become a digital
marketing specialist learning paths
explored you can see that's an h1 but
below it's a sub header the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an h2 and so we're not stretching to
Google that that's a more important than
an h1 but nonetheless we're stressing to
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized ok the next element we want to
focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if we remember earlier
in the presentation
it's basically links from one page on
your website to another and so here we
can see on this particular article how
to become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social
Media marketing specialists and digital
marketing specialists so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learn is doing here is offering
up other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building an internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end user
experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad - there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you wanted to use
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more nach
and so that's what we mean a natural
language processing we want to choose
keywords that are more natural to the
content you're writing so instead of the
keyword digital marketing maybe we want
to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist so those are all relevant
keywords to digital marketing and more
relevant to the content because if you
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing again it's probably going to
be a little bit broad probably more
competition not as relevant to your
content and as a result probably not a
good user experience so think about some
other keywords that you could optimize
and rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the site map and so with
a site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so they're do
two types of sitemaps one is an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simply learn calm
and simply type in say sitemap XML just
as an example I'm gonna get this
take your page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps
so these sitemaps are there for Google
to go ahead and crawl and nothing more
than a list of all the pages on your
website and so this is a quick and easy
way for Google to get ahold of all those
pages so that they can index them and
that's the whole idea behind SEO you
want to be able to have Google index all
the content you want to be found for for
the keywords you want to be found for so
it all starts with the sitemap so let's
go from on-page SEO which in recap is
basically optimizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for particular keyword and that man
updating the title tag the Meta
Description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having an internal linking and
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're gonna switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together
so you can do as much as you want on
on-page but you still need off page SEO
and you could do all the off page SEO
you want but you still need on-page so
both of these strategies have to be in
full effect in order for you to rank so
let's now switch gears to off page SEO
and so off page SEO is simply the
process of linking or promoting your
website using link building and so if
you remember I talked about this earlier
on there's two types of Link's internal
and external linking and so for on-page
SEO we used internal linking for off
page SEO we're going to talk about
external linking and external linking
allows us to improve our website's
recognition or relevancy or credibility
and why do we want to prove our
relevance incredible 'ti and
trustworthiness and authority because we
want Google to know that our web page is
trustworthy it is recognized by other
websites and it is relevant for a
particular keyword and so if we can do
using off-page SEO methods think
Google's going to rank our webpage for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off page SEO is synonymous
with link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building and
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website but also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
Authority is going to improve and when
our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
authority for us and it helps drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility trustworthiness and it's
going to in turn help us rank for that
particular page and then certainly not
last having a good off page SEO link
building strategy increases our brand
awareness because if we're on either
high authority websites Wikipedia or say
a social platform it's going to increase
our brand awareness and increase in our
brand awareness increases our
trustworthiness and so if somebody is
looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on Google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to off
page SEO so it's nothing more than
having links on other websites that are
pointing back to ours and again there's
lots of benefits
it's drives helps drive traffic and
increases our authority so those are
things that we want to take advantage of
when we want to rank and the key behind
off page SEO or link building is always
going to be content
so from an on-page SEO perspective
having quality content allows that
content to be optimized for relevant
keyword and ranked but also from an off
page SEO strategy having high quality
content allows us to have other sites
and it doesn't necessarily form or can
be another blogging platform or blogging
website link back to ours why because
the content is original it's natural
it's well structured and reads well and
so that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're gonna link to
it they don't necessarily have to wait
for you to ask them but it might not be
a bad idea to understand who else is out
there that has content some what are
yours so that you can you know get a
link
that particular website or blog post and
so some other ideas behind having
external links pointing back to your
website is social media so social media
is not just Facebook or Twitter but it
expands beyond that there's there's core
there's media there's all sorts of
content generated web sites like Reddit
so the list goes on and on you just need
to find what's relevant for your content
if it's relevant for your content
then it's worth putting or trying to get
the external link on that social media
platform and then again going back to my
icecream blog recipes blog post yeah if
you find a particular blog that you want
to have an external link on there's
nothing wrong with reaching out to that
particular blogger you know in some
cases very flattering but in other cases
if the content is relevant then why not
it's only going to help your end user
experience if you add somebody who has
up say a blog about cakes having their
link on your blog post so there's
nothing wrong with it because it also
adds to the user experience and if
you're gonna ask somebody to put an
external link on theirs you might want
to be open-minded and make sure that
your are able and willing to put an
external link on your blog post or
website pointing to their content that's
how the web works especially if the
contents of quality relevant and of good
nature ok so let's move on and finish up
with the do's and don'ts of SEO so we
talked a lot about why SEO what is SEO
you know how do we rank for SEO you know
what is on-page SEO what is off page SEO
and so let's just wrap up with some of
the things you again want to do to rank
your page for particular keyword and
some of the things you don't want to do
so the first thing on the list is
optimize for white hat techniques and
what I mean for opting in for white hat
techniques is basically everything I
just mentioned today you want to do
keyword research you want to choose a
natural language processing form format
so you can choose keywords that are
going to be relevant natural to the
content and you don't want to opt for
black cat technique
black hat techniques are probably not
even worth going into detail but one
example is choosing a keyword
arbitrarily likes a digital marketing
and just stuffing that keyword into the
content so that's probably not something
you want to do because again it's not
gonna be good for the end-user so stay
away from blackhat and focus on some of
the techniques we talked about in
today's presentation the other do we
want to do is get backlinks from
relevant sites so that's off page SEO
again it's what I mentioned earlier it's
about linking your quality content to
another person's website that also has
quality content we don't want to have a
backlink from an irrelevant site why
because it's not gonna be relevant and
it's also gonna hurt our Authority
because if it's on a site that's not of
good quality then Google's gonna look at
us and say well this site is linking to
your site but it's not relevant so
therefore you know we're not going to
look at you in the same way as if you
were on a quality website we do want to
use our keywords naturally because title
tags are what people see first on
organic search but you don't want to use
the same title tag on every page of your
website so we want to stay away from
doing that so you want to have a unique
title tag for every web page on your
website and ideally what does that mean
that means using our keyword research to
choose one or two keywords per page and
optimizing your webpage for those one to
two keywords so you ideally what you
want to do is have one to two different
keywords for every page on your website
we definitely definitely definitely want
to write engaging content so the content
should be engaging remember user
experience we want users to stay on our
website we want them to enjoy the
content that they're reading and we want
them to go from one page to another
naturally we definitely don't want to
leverage or plagiarize or just copy
content from others websites because
it's not one probably going to be
relevant to what you're writing about -
its duplicate content and it's somebody
else's so that's a black cat technique
we want to stay away from I can't
emphasize this enough we need to do
keyword research first before you do
anything else you need to find relevant
keywords and not only that you need to
understand the volume and the
competition for each of those keywords
okay you don't want to choose a keyword
that has low volume high competition you
want to choose a keyword that has high
volume low competition but above all you
want to choose keywords that are
relevant to your content we want to
avoid keyword stuffing so don't take a
keyword and just stuff it everywhere on
the page it's not going to be natural
and Google's gonna be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keywords that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the homepage or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural
naturally linking from one page to
another not only does it help Google
understand and crawl all the web pages
on your website but it's good for the
end user it's good user experience and
certainly last but something I didn't
talk about does take time to rank your
content so remember the process you're
going to write your content you're going
to choose keywords you're going to
change the elements on that page for
those keywords and all the while you're
gonna make sure Google can crawl that
content and when they crawl it they're
going to index it the process takes time
especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page SEO and off page
SEO then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's
user-friendly and mobile-friendly so
when we talked about responsive content
earlier so remember most users today
start the process of search on mobile so
we want to make sure your website's are
friendly so I want to thank you for
joining me today I look forward to
seeing you on other simply learn
presentations - thank you for your time
and for more information please feel
free to visit simply learn comm thank
you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here